good morning everybody
welcome to to this meeting of the
licensing
and regulatory committee the 11th of
june 2021
i will now ask the government's office
officer to read out
the domestic arrangements karen if you
could please
thank you chair please ensure that you
maintain
social distance from all other persons
in the chamber and in the social areas
please also ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking
or if you're unable to do so and that
you use hand sanitizer and wipes
provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and during any
breaks
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair
we'll be using the evoting on mod.gov
for this meeting
i would like to remind everyone present
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consented to being recorded
by the council
and the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record film or photograph
this meeting when the public and the
press are not lawfully excluded
thanks chair thank you karen right um
we'll now move on um could the officers
introduce yourself
first of all emma
yes good morning emma rich bell i'm the
assistant manager food safety and
licensing
uh catherine um
uh catherine green licensing officer
perry
good morning karen say governance
officer thank you i'll now move to the
agenda
apologies for absence
margaret thank you um
[Music]
thank you i would like to make a
statement um i would move that this
committee
has no confidence in the chairman or the
vice chairman
and i move that there is a vote on that
subject
all right legal advice on that is that a
time and place
um it's new to me but
if there's a seconder then i don't see
the reason why you can't hold the vote
but um the chairman and the vice
chairman
have been elected full council by
by all the councillors so i can't see
and it wasn't close
it was quite a substantial so i can't
see the point
within the constitution and rob will
read out the
relevant clause at any time
a committee member may raise the subject
of no confidence in the chairman
and i do this as we are bringing the
taxi fares back for the third time to
this
licence committee and there has also
been other issues within
the other subcommittees which are
confidential um
and i have the backing of the other
members
beside and behind me
would you like to read that out please
well thank you
is
chair um i'll just read out
the relevant point under the
constitution so that we're all clear
that what council maybe is referring to
that is part so this is under
part three the committee and
subcommittee procedure rules
paragraph four um which outlines that
remover of the chairman at any meeting
of a committee or subcommittee a council
may propose
that the meeting has no confidence in
the chairman now i
i do realize that council maybe did
mention the vice chairman so i believe
it can only be the chair
and not the vice chair at the same time
i would obviously defer if there's any
other interpretation of that
that mr dulu would go on that but that
is my interpretation as it writes in
this constitution
that seems quite clear and then it goes
on to say
that the question shall after debate be
put
and if carried by a majority of at least
two-thirds of
the council as present the chairman
shall stand down and the remainder of
the meeting will be chaired by the vice
chair
or in his or her absence by a councillor
elected
for that purpose by the meeting so in
this case i don't believe the vice chair
is here is that correct
that's correct so in that case it would
be that a new chair would have to be
elected
um following a successful vote of no
confidence in the chair if
in the elected sorry following a
successful vote of no confidence in the
elected chairman
he or she shall not officiate any at any
subsequent meeting
of the committee or subcommittee prior
to the next council meeting
and at the next meeting the council
shall consider whether to confirm
or not the vote of no confidence if by a
simple majority the council shall decide
to confirm the vote
the office of chairman of the relevant
committee shall be declared vacant
and a new chairman shall be elected by
the council now i
i'm just uh i've got this in my book
here just to work out that it would be
two-thirds majority would be five
members
out of us out of the seven as you cannot
have a person cut in half as such so it
would be
the actual one would be 4.6 but it would
be five because that'll be the required
part
thank you chairman
thank you mr chairman could you could
you just clarify
that the photon of five members is that
five members out of the
ten that are uh listed in on the agenda
or is this um out of the members that
are attending
if i made sure the um that would be of
the members present
at the meeting
so it's value members out of the
members that are present yes sorry that
calculation is based on the members that
are present here
at this moment but there's there's ten
members on the um
um on this committee and i don't know
there's uh
one two
oh i'm sorry am i you know one two
[Music]
three four five people missing
there's only one oh no there is more
people here sorry
i hadn't seen them all behind me thank
you pardon
sorry if i might just clarify chair this
specific wording in there is that
by a majority of at least two-thirds of
the council is present
is the specific writing in the
constitution
to do this i think i'd like to
cancel this meeting and wait till we
vote again at full council can that be
done
because it's ridiculous no i'm advised
against the chair i think we need to go
through the process it's set out in the
constitution and we need to follow the
constitution okay i'll take your advice
on that so
now i know you'd like to propose it
margaret
yes who is your seconder
well i'm very disappointed with both of
you
on a point of order i think you have to
ask
for a seconder and that person needs to
acknowledge that they're second in them
i don't think i can be proposed by the
proposer of the
of the first part of it john is a second
did it yeah
do you want him to john behind you just
seconded
yeah john's this second did it i've just
done that
okay so what is the procedure now we go
through
right we take a vote then all in favor
of
keeping me as chairman
me just give maddie a minute then
um
so
uh
[Music]
so the motion is the vote of no
confidence
it's just gone off on here
signing and my computer's not working
yes certainly catherine
excuse me you may ask a question please
yes certainly kevin thank you
um once the wording
is on there could we have advice from
the lawyer
um as to how we should
vote because depending on how the
questions are expressed
um could we have guidance on how we
should vote because this isn't
okay
if you agree with the vote of no
confidence then it's a yes
if you agree if you disagree with the
motion then it's a no
thank you
mr chairman could i just ask a question
does the six-month rule apply
that because this came up at the full
council meeting and that's less than six
months ago
and i'm sure robert give me the answer i
believe from
what we call fun from the from the
constitution it's at any time
okay councillors that vote is now open
in the mod.gov apps
okay that vote the result of the vote is
five four and two again
so that's carried chair
the constitution um has to be ratified
that the council understand
um so we continue with this committee
um and then it needs to be put to a vote
of majority
through the full council i think that's
my understanding of it
mr chairman can we just be clear on that
it seems
we've obviously voted here on a request
to remove the present chairman
and you're now saying that although that
vote went
went for removing the present chairman
he remains and we've got to wait now for
a full council decision perhaps if you
could read out the
from the constitution again i don't know
whether the people that put this forward
was aware of all that
i was going to say i think that if i
read it out again for
clarity on us so that we will have um
have it all understand what is before us
then so
as the majority of at least two-thirds
has been carried off those members
present
the following uh point will now take
place following a
successful vote of no confidence in the
elected chairman
he or she shall not officiate at any
subsequent meeting
which would include in my understanding
today the rest of today's meeting
at any subsequent meeting of the
committee or subcommittee prior to the
next council meeting
at the meeting of the at the next
council meeting
the council shall consider whether to
confirm or not the vote of no confidence
that has taken place here today if by a
simple majority and this is at the
council meeting council
shall decide to confirm the vote the
office of the chairman
of the relevant committee shall be
declared vacant and a new chairman shall
be elected by the council so that
that procedure happens when the next
full council meeting
takes place can i just come back i think
that's rather
um badly worded i accept what you're
saying
and mr carmichael because it really puts
the chairman in a
bad situation um that he can continue
and share a meeting
which half of his or five members of the
committee
don't wish him to um
it's really um not a nice situation
i'm not sure whether the people who
voted this way fought it through i don't
know
catherine it seemed to me
when you read it obviously i've only
heard it not seen it
but oh sorry thank you
um that in this circumstance that
the vice chairman who obviously isn't
here today should take the rest
of today's meeting um and that then
it goes to a vote at full council
and that the vice chairman if there are
any further meetings before the next
full council meeting
that the vice chairman should send
but obviously the vice chairman isn't
here today
so should we maybe vote as to
how today's meeting should or discuss
how
today's meeting should proceed
if i could just clarify what the next
steps are so that we're all
aware of what happens next so following
that vote
and the vice chair is not present as we
alluded as boys pointed out earlier
a vote must now be taken on for a chair
for this meeting only
not for the subsequent meetings as i
understand it because the vice chair
will take over if they are
present at the next meetings and um i
would ask my colleague karen sayer
to do that um now so that a new chair
can be formed a business can continue
thank you
just a quick question robert um
i understand fully what what you've said
can you take your mask off i can't
understand sorry
sorry i understand fully what you said
um
if at the next four council meeting um
councillor newman um was to win the vote
and uh
goes back into the chair position can it
be challenged again
can can this be repetitive where things
are challenged more than once
rather than me um answer all the
questions that perhaps i
shouldn't answer without consulting the
monitoring officer i would ask
if you put that question to the
monitoring officer and to ask what
if that is a situation that could happen
because i don't feel
that it's a my place to comment on that
at this time but the question is valid
to the monitoring yes because i wasn't
being rude but i just wonder
anyone in the position that the chair is
here that could happen
in any committee
i would doubt it because it disrupts the
meeting every time doesn't it it's
ridiculous once you've been voted in on
full council you should be able to do
them
do it for a year and you you know make
your decision
at full council yes certainly
i have had on more than one occasion the
comment made
mr chairman as you are now
well you're not the chairman at the
moment now um
that the the business of the licensing
and regulatory committee
interferes with your business hence
that's why you are always in such a
hurry
to end a meeting um and we have also
had taxi fares come back for the third
time
if you read the minutes you will see
that i queried
about the discrimination for equality
previously none of this has been picked
up by either you or the vice chairman
and for those reasons that's why i have
challenged you
in your position you have lost that vote
and i would suggest for your own
personal
um position that you retire gracefully
from this meeting and let us carry on
with the taxi fares which is what we're
here to do
well first of all i'm going to answer
that
um it doesn't interfere with my business
because i just close
i mean i can retire tomorrow if i want
to i think
mr chairman could i i think we need to
move on with uh with
with the nomination for for a new chair
so we can get the business i
i don't really subject yourself to any
more of this um
attack well i think it's absolutely
disgusting
and especially when it's you lost a vote
margaret it's just sour grapes
i think mr chairman okay
so we'll go through the vote for
chairman then
personally i think we don't want to get
personal let's just get on with it
no i'm not getting personal but
everybody just
nominations for a chair to take over
today's meeting please
counseling i propose council maybe
thank you is that seconded councillor
creswell
okay we need to vote on that is the vote
ready mandy
okay the vote is ready in the mod.gov
app
we're voting for councillor mabry to
chair the meeting
okay the result was five four and two
again so that's carried and
councillor maybe is elected chairman of
this meeting
unless there are logistic issues i would
say stay where we are because of the the
covered restrictions
um thank you very much and
um councillors i've been hit the wrong
button i've come right out of this
does it matter no go back into mod go
beg your partner thank you very much
um fellow councillors and we will
continue with the agenda
um and this is friday the 11th
of june and this meeting now starts at 9
58 according to my computer
item 1 on the agenda is substitutes and
apologies do we have any karen
please thank you we have received
apologies from councillor carpendale and
councillor dawson
and is there anything from councillor
gould please i haven't received anything
from councillor gold
thank you very much thank you and we
have no substitutions
today no thank you very much
item two is declaration of interests
has there been any declaration of
interest please
from any counsellor it would be for
councillors to declare that now
but nothing in writing no
i can't see you all right thank you very
much
um and item three will be to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 11th
of december 2020 and that is pages
five to eight on your screen
i'm just going to have to scroll down
for this
right for accuracy
are there any comments on page five
of the minutes which is the first page
of the minutes
that should be it i think peter
that is it you've just gone past it
that's the first page you've just downed
long past
okay we'll go on to the next page which
is
page six
um for accuracy and then
page seven for accuracy any counsellors
any issues with any of those please
no no um
karen may i ask are these signed or are
these just taken as
um as confirmed because they are
recorded please
we need to take a vote chair thank you
very much
would you like me to um conduct the
votes you need a proposal and second
well i'll propose them if i may thank
you and a second
for the minutes please i'm in the
disadvantage because i can't see anyone
i'm sorry
perhaps i'll have to rely on the on the
screens thank you
chair if it helps i've um emailed you
the order of proceedings for this
morning
thank you and i've just managed to
knock the not the computer as i turned
around
right we've got a proposal from a
seconder to confirm the minutes
um and the vote is ready in the mod.gov
app
thank you and if all councillors could
vote please
hmm
and the result is five four and two
abstains
so that's carried thank you very much
and just have to get the page back up
again
thank you we move on to the agenda and
item four is to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received chair thank you
item five is questions from councillors
have you received any please
none receive chair thank you item six
madam chairman can i ask a question
questions
from counsellors do these have to be
written in beforehand or can questions
can i dream up a question now
those questions to be submitted um
before the meeting there's a
deadline which i believe is could that
be included underpaid in future
that made it look like anybody could
just ask the question
that just tidies up thank you robert
according to the constitution okay it's
um
questions by councillors in accordance
with the constitution
i think rob wishes to comment
i may share this under the the
um questions from councillors rule
that's first specifically for counselors
who are not at the meeting so
the council at the meeting can ask any
question um but it's specifically the
questions from
from counselors is anyone who is not on
the committee and wouldn't be present at
the meeting to us so council beer can
ask questions relating obviously to
anything that's before us today
or anything regarding licensing um if
that helps chair
this moment it can be asked at
any moment if yeah okay
you have a question would you like to
ask could i could we know
um how the photon went uh earlier
we we wasn't very clear
um do we know who's voted
or can you remind us of the exact vote
and figures again because i couldn't
really hear at that time
the vote for the no confidence in the
chair
the yes um the result was five
four and two against one
[Music]
thank you any other questions from
councillors
no thank you we'll we will move on to
item six which is
blr stroke 21 stroke 2
hackney carriage table affairs review
this is on
pages 9 to 16 for councillors in their
pack and i hand over to emma richbell
welcome and thank you
thank you cher this report refers to
review
of the current table affairs fixed for
hackney carriages operating in the
controlled zone of baber district
the committee will be aware that this
review process has been extended and
problematic
with earlier proposals being rejected by
cabinet and most recently
suspended following a cabinet
recommendation to adopt
i regret the errors made to date and
would like to briefly summarize the work
undertaken by the licensing team over
the last few weeks
to ensure that the proposal before you
today is fit for purpose
the starting point this time was the
trade itself
we had received a number of tariff
proposals from drivers
operators and meter agents and we use
these to develop
three tariff proposals which would
provide an increased income for the
trade
whilst being affordable for the
travelling public and
in particular would not penalize those
who are only able to travel in one of
the larger
wheelchair accessible vehicles
the three drone proposals were shared by
email with all operators
and self-employed drivers of hackney
carriages
asking them to express a preference
ahead of the formal consultation
unfortunately the response to this was
very small but the draft proposal before
you today was the preferred option
the draft table affairs is based on
passenger numbers
rather than vehicle size and rates 2
and 3 serve dual purposes for example
rate 2
which is the night time rate for one to
four passengers
also serves as the daytime rate for five
to eight passengers
the report and proposed tariff has been
subject to an equality impact assessment
in accordance with the council's
procedures
we are also currently undertaking a
survey of the use of taxis and private
hire vehicles
by those with disabilities to
investigate whether the current
provision is adequate
this is primarily to inform the ongoing
review of the taxi policy
but there will also be an opportunity to
take these findings into account
before any new tariff comes into force
officers are therefore proposing two
options for the committee's
consideration
option one that no change be made to the
table affairs
or option two to create a clear
and concise draft table affairs showing
four tariffs
with tariffs one to three for vehicles
carrying one to four passengers
and tariffs two to four for vehicles
carrying five to eight passengers
recommendations are that the committee
consider the two options
and that should the committee wish to
recommend a cabinet
to amend the table affairs as per the
attached appendix a
that they instruct officers to proceed
with a public consultation notice
advertising the variations in accordance
with section 65
of the local government miscellaneous
provisions act 1976
the very table affairs shall become
effective from the 1st of november
2021 and i'd like to draw your attention
that's a small amendment
the report gives the date of the 18th of
october
we've decided to extend this just by a
couple of weeks to ensure the trade have
sufficient time to make the practical
changes to the meters that will be
required
in accordance with section 65 of the
local government miscellaneous
provisions act
1976 once a table of fares is buried
a notice containing the fair table must
be advertised in a local newspaper
with a similar notice published at the
council offices
any objections received after this will
need to be considered as a future
meeting of the licensing and regulatory
committee
this is a statutory function and the
legislation provides for recovery of the
reasonable costs of administration
inspection and supervision of the
licensing scheme
in particular the cost to providing the
public notice
necessary for commencement of the public
consultation
is contained within the fees collected
as part of the licensing budget
act does not set out a specific right of
appeal where a council has adopted a
maximum table affairs for hackney
carriages
however the fair table may from time to
time be subject to judicial review
consultation and compliance with the
prescribed notice requirements mitigate
the main risks
and finally i wish to draw the
committee's attention
to a slight change of wording to the
recommendation
at 3.2
so at 3.2 where the report states
that should the committee resolve to
amend the table affairs
it will of course be for cabinets to
make the final decision
but for the committee today to recommend
to cabinet that the fares be amended
so that's a recommendation rather than a
resolution
that concludes my summary but i will do
my best to answer any questions
and thank you very thank you very much
emma for that
um i do have a couple of questions so
i'm going to start if i may and then
hopefully
other councillors will follow if they
have any
um your comment was that there was very
small response from the trade
i thought that the trade were actually
going to be
here today
um obviously they're not and i and they
they were it's being live streamed
clearly they may well be watching on the
live stream
um it's always difficult isn't it you
you put out information there for people
to respond
to and they don't always respond as you
would like it was it was a tiny number
i think it was five or six responses out
of the entire trade which is
disappointing but
it was an attempt just ahead of the
formal consultation to get a feel if we
could
for the which would be preferred of the
of the three so
we did our best we had a small response
we are going with one that was most
popular from that very small response
okay
i'm going to come back emma because um
obviously you know i've been very
supportive of you
over this issue and i have spoken to you
i am just a little concerned that the
trade has lost a bit of confidence in
us as the licensing committee and i
would hope
that once this is resolved once and for
all
that we will have a better relationship
with them
um i think that's fair to say that's not
a criticism of you because i have been
very supportive of you
my second question is where
are wheelchair users going in this
tariff please so
as a wheelchair user now you are able to
use a larger vehicle and be charged no
more than you would be for an able
possum
able-bodied passenger using a saloon car
so that's obviously a primary objective
of this proposal
and that and that will be fixed
absolutely
absolutely thank you very much my other
comment following on from that and i did
use wheelchairs
is that it does actually involve all
types of mobility
assistance apparatus um i have
experience of this
my husband has a i call it a walker
it's an aid which is supposed to fit in
any boot of any car
i can assure you it does not it needs
its own
seat within a vehicle and i think as a
licensing committee
we should be very aware of the facts
that this these apparatuses do not
compact as much as um as everyone says
that they do
um it's very very exciting if i have a
grandchild in the back of the car and i
need to put a walker in there as well
so i try not to take both out uh did
council
councillors wanted to comment on this
too please
thank you very much and thank you for
all your work emma
must have taken your ass really
appreciated um can i ask
um sort of a ballpark number of how many
drivers or taxi operators were contacted
out of the few that have responded thank
you
can i ask catherine if she actually did
the email response for that to give you
the numbers if that's
okay thank you hello
um we sent them all out to the hackney
carriage
proprietors and um we got
five responses from them but it was sent
to anybody who owns a hackney carriage
ballpark i think we've got about 10 or
11
um independent drivers and or companies
that that drive on
on that hackney cash rank
thank you very much for replying to that
um so so basically it's about 50 in
those sort of terms because i must admit
it's more than i thought because i
thought we sent it to all individual
drivers which would have been a larger
number but
on that basis it is 50 yes okay thank
you very much
um councillor beer wish to ask a
question and then i'll go to my other
thank you madam chairman i'm sorry
that's anyway get your attention
inside look behind me there um just to
point out that
you you madden weren't solely the only
council at the last meeting that was
concerned about the
taxi drivers um being consulted
and attended and certainly
10.8 in the minutes i did ask the
question about regarding the public
consultation exercises and the responses
received
i'm still concerned that we don't seem
to have got
really any response from them
as of last time because
it came to the committee we were told
that um i think there was one and i
could be corrected
madam chairman and that i'm not quite
correct on this but
i seem to think that there was one or
two
taxi drivers that was beaten on behalf
of the rest of them
and was voicing an opinion that they
weren't happy
and yet we were led to believe by
officers that all these people
had more or less been contacted and that
they all agreed with what was going
forward
and i think this is why it was put
forward
as i say i wasn't happy at the time and
others weren't
but now i'm not sure
whether they're happy or not because
no one's here as the chairman has said
and
um we haven't heard from them so
i just wonder whether we should get a
response
or go back to them have you had
communications and can you
say with hand on heart that they're
they're all happy and prepared to go
along with this
because we don't want to find ourselves
in another situation where it all has to
come back to us again
thank you yep so obviously this the
proposal today is to go to that
consultation
a further time with the trade the
letters are ready to go so they'll get
actual hard copy letter
each member of the trade that's to be
consulted
and we encourage them to respond to the
consultation
it's difficult to do any more than that
but they are all going to get a letter
and an opportunity um
thank you emma uh councillor grandin
thank you chair um can you just clarify
when you say each member of the trade
you mean
each individual member or each company
please again catherine as you prepared
the letters to go would you like to
explain thank you yeah and so every
single driver any owner of an operator
and each operator itself is getting a
letter so everybody's going to be
consulted
um if if i may comment both to emma and
and catherine and i'm sorry to leave our
trainee
out at the back but um if i can just ask
both of you
we the taxi fares have not been reviewed
since 2016.
my memory serves me right correct we
have a statutory period
i think that we have to review them or
is that not statutory it's just
the best of my knowledge there's no
statutory period the intention would be
after this review to review them
annually so that there was a small
increment on an annual basis it'd be
much simpler
you'll recall that initially we were
looking to change the structure of the
fares so they're based on percentages
we're still doing that um so once we've
got a
a fair which is uh tariff which is much
more fit for purpose then we would
intend to do an annual small increase on
that
thank you and if i can just come back on
that
you are suggesting that um these new
fares come
in on the first of november um
would the annual review be on the
november date or would it
tie in to the
usual financial year please
i can see you thank you um like with our
statement of licensing policy and
statement of gambling principles we
didn't
attempt to do the work prior to the
first november date
in order to to get that through for the
first of november once again when we
review it
for next year so so it would start about
three months
prior about three months before but
we're looking at a november
annual it would be implemented to come
in each november when we do after the
review
thank you um councillor cresswell has a
question
and i'm sorry well this isn't really a
question it's a bit more of a point
really
it's um i agree sending out a
paper copy or a hard copy to all the
drivers but
uh i think sorry but i think
the realism is you won't please
everybody all the time
so although say i'm just making a figure
up 50.
you might get 35 who say that's great
and you all get 15 who don't so
you we're going to have to go for
majority well anyway so
that's just my opinion
um councillor beer and thank you for
letting me come back so just pursuing
that point you're writing these letters
we're going to get responses back from
them
uh will we then
supposing the responses come back that
they're not happy
surely that will knock out 3.2 which was
a recommendation to take this forward to
cabinet
so how are we going to proceed because
again if they're not happy about it then
we
we need to look at it before it goes to
cabinet
um so can 3.2 still be left in or should
we omit that
and insert something that allows us to
hear back from the taxi drivers
my understanding is that we would
receive consultation responses
we would if we felt it's appropriate
necessary
further amend the tariff proposal to
come back to licensing regulatory
committee
for further consideration for them to
recommend if they wished
to cabinet to adopt it
council of beer yes reply please
um yes so what you're saying then
is that um the result of the
consultation
will come back to this committee before
we send
act 3.2 is that correct that's correct
because
i think this is where we've went wrong
last time
that's great that's my understanding
have i made myself clear ladies and
gentlemen yes
good
hello um thank you very much for
confirming that
um the consultation period um
are you the letters that are going out
to the taxi operators
what sort of period of time will they be
given please
i believe that's four weeks
28 days specifically yes okay 28 days
sounds great
thank you very much so we we are
anticipating if
if i may just to do a resume on this
that if the committee is minded
to put this forward that
then the letters will go out to the taxi
operators they will have 28
days and i'm assuming from monday they
will have 28 days to reply
they will then be co-lated and then
time scale for bringing it back to the
committee please
um this is due to come back to committee
on the
13th of august thank you
thank you very much so we have we have a
time frame
um any other questions from any
counsellors
no no other counsellor wishes to make
any comments on this
um i would
also like to comment if i may on the
survey that's gone out for the
um for the disability
apparatus users um i have seen it um i
have completed it on behalf of
of family and i have mentioned to emma
that
i thought it should be apparatus rather
than wheelchairs for the reasons that i
have already
um spoken about when do we anticipate
that this survey will
give us some information please
again that's running for a month it's
going to early july
so we'll have some information there and
you'll be aware that i've asked
stockholm's team to
give a preamble in the social media post
to explain that anyone who has
mobility issues obviously very welcome
to contribute
yes and i did get that to email
and i have gone back to our
communications officer
and said that i agree with the first
line of the paragraph
and but not the second because it again
states wheelchair users
only and i have asked for that to be
amended
i think we are sometimes too quick to
assume
that all those with less ability
use a wheelchair and that is not correct
but thank you emma for
taking that on board and thank you also
to jessica who's also taken that on
board
thank you so councillors um
we have before us the proposal we
also have appendix a which is the rates
can i just ask have any counsellors any
questions on the actual ratings
which is appendix a please
it had um i'll get you that
get to you in a moment um counselor it
has been
um confirmed by our licensing officer
that those who use the mobility device
will be
will not be charged the the higher
amount yes thank you
thank you very much for confirming that
uh councillor beer
thank you madam chairman um regarding
the
uh the affairs have these been
accepted and seen by the taxi drivers do
that are they
um quite happy with this have they had
any input into it
again it's coming back to this business
as um
as agreeing to it and then we find that
they know nothing about it absolutely
so to explain further um the appendix a
really is
is based on some proposals from the
trade and from
some of the meter agents who are the
people that reprogram the meters
so they'd put forward some alternatives
to what we were proposing um
early in the year and last year we took
that as a starting point
so this is based on the trades proposals
if you like
um because we we're not experts in taxi
tariffs and they are quite honestly
so that's a starting point obviously
there's been a pre-consultation
attempt to ask them what they would like
a bit more
and now it will be an opportunity for
them to be formally consulted so it's
come from the trade
and it's going to go back to the trade
to see if they're happy with it
hopefully this time
thank you uh councillor grandin has a
question
thank you i've got two questions if i
may please yes i do
carry on um firstly like
what were the original
or the previous rates have they gone up
by a percentage
or how have you worked out or had you
consulted
um but how have you worked out the
the rates please and and
you know what again are they a
percentage and secondly
are these the rates that for example
a local authority or a health authority
or someone would pay if they have to use
um taxis for regular
use are they the same rates that might
be a gap in my
knowledge but um please could you tell
me that as well please
i'll answer the second first if i may so
this is that that'd be the maximum fare
for anyone travelling
in a hackney carriage it's the maximum
fare there's always an opportunity
for a lesser fare to be charged if
that's agreeable to the the driver and
the passenger
but it's the maximum to anyone so that's
a yeah absolute maximum for
whoever's traveling um private high
vehicles you'll be aware
there's no fixed maximum so there it's
agreed
between the traveler and the driver or
the operator and
regards the percentage increase it's
very difficult really to say because you
may recall from previous discussions
that the the fair which is to the
tariffs but still currently in operation
is itself based on percentages so
there's a daytime fare
you increase by 50 for the night time
and 100
for the the bank holidays to christmas
new year times
so in actual fact it's very difficult to
say at the minute
today what is being charged because the
percentage is
of course confusion really and what the
maximum fare is
so i can't give you a percentage
increase that it represents
what i can do if it's helpful i can give
you some example journeys and what the
cost is currently and what it would be
so we we did we calculated three sort of
typical journeys for baby district so
we've got a
town centre to tesco's out of town
currently you would pay five pounds 84
as the maximum
under the proposed tariff would be six
pounds 26
then a slightly longer journey from
sudbury to bilderson health centre
that's currently 19 pounds and 12 and
would be
21 pounds 20 and then we've got a longer
journey from sudbury to west suburban
hospital
currently 28 pounds 40 would be 31
pounds 64.
so i think really from the point of view
of the traveler
relatively modest increase when you work
it out as
as best we can as a percentage it comes
out around 10
or so which sounds quite a lot but then
again the drivers the operators trade
haven't had an increase since 2016.
so from that point of view as an annual
increase i think it's reasonable
um thank you councillor grandin did that
answer all your questions
thank you thank you um any more
questions yes council councillor is
please
thank you very much um some of our
apparitionists and greg's have
complained that they're only allowed to
use the taxi vouchers
for one trip to the hospital but not
coming back
can you clarify the reasoning behind
that case i can explain
the short answer is i can't
unfortunately i think the taxi vouchers
are administered by suffolk county
council rather than ourselves
so i can take that away and have a look
but i can't answer it for you right now
i'm afraid the council is
and councillors you said you wanted to
explain
further why no i'm misunderstood i'm
very
sorry i misunderstood you thank you um
the comments that i have had from
the trade and they have been talking to
me
is the fact that the larger vehicles
obviously cost more in
original cost of the actual vehicle more
cost for the insurance
petrol diesel whatever fuel they are
using
um can you comment please emma or
catherine
as to what they have said to you as
regard
these prices now please
the message loud and clear from those
that we've spoken to has been that they
only want the ability to charge more for
more passengers
and that would give them sufficient
income to operate those larger vehicles
um i mean that that they have been
saying that for some months and
we haven't really heard that from them
properly but we are now
that's what they really want is the
ability to charge for the five to eight
passengers when they carry that many
but they don't want to be able to have
to charge that for everyone
and i give an example of a self-employed
driver who has a larger vehicle
and he said to me i don't want to have
to charge a bigger flag fare for one
person i won't get any trade
i only have that one large vehicle so
that's why
we really need to based on passenger
numbers rather than the vehicle size
itself and can we achieve that
that's what this will achieve yeah yes
just confirming councillor beer you had
a question
well i think you went on to answer it
but i will just
get clarification so when you say that
sorry i'll take that off um you're
saying that
when they carry more passengers
is this over four and so if they've got
five six or seven that's when the price
will go up
that's correct so we're quite clear on
that that up to four
will just be the one rate yes but if if
there's
value or six or seven passengers
then there would be the additional
charge per person it's
it means you you move up a tariff
basically so it means that the fair the
flag fair the fair appears as soon as
you get in the vehicle will be higher
if you're five to eight passengers
um thank you council beer thank you
thank you emma um
and and the trade are happy with doing
that
and the metering personnel can deal with
that too
thank you that's right we made sure to
to run it by the meter agents if you
like to make sure that that's
practically possible and it is
thank you thank you any other questions
counsellors
counselor newman nothing from you
just quick comment um i understood peter
up to four people be a certain tariff
and then
five onwards would be another tariff
if four people went in to a seven or
eight-seater
taxi and
say we would go to whipstitch for an
evening out
how do you know what tariff will be in
charge really as a customer
the um vehicles are required to display
the tariffs so it should be clear
when you enter the vehicle as to what
you would be paying if based on the
number of passengers
and obviously the the fare is displayed
as you travel
so you should be able to check what's
being displayed on the meter against the
the advertised tariff yeah i understand
that but
i i don't think the general public would
know if it's a tariff for four people or
one for
for the larger amount of people that's
that's all i'm getting at okay
usually not being rude we agree a price
if we go out of town
and uh so we know what we're getting
into but just
in actual fact if you if you're
traveling outside of the controlled
zone of baby district a fare can be
agreed in that way but it
still mustn't be more than the meter
would display
um thank you emma so to confirm
for for instance because you used this
um
example previously someone from sudbury
traveling to the west suffolk hospital
which is out of baby district council
they could negotiate their price
that's correct yes right how do we
get that message across to the public
please
well it's it's the same message really
for all journeys because you can always
negotiate a lower fare than that
displayed on the meter anyway it can't
be higher than that
so it's a good point and maybe we need
to raise public awareness of it
that the displayed fare is the maximum
chargeable
oh thank you and i i think that is
absolutely correct
um hopefully we will be able to get back
to our parish liaison meetings
in the future and we'll be able to take
that message out to the public
which will be to initially parish
councils and other
associations then we can get that
message out um
i have seen you councillor brandon i'll
come back
what i am seeing
my vision in in the future and i'm sure
my colleagues will probably agree with
me
is that we are having an influx of
people
into our area and also that they are
older
and perhaps will not be using their own
motorized vehicle
so we really do need to get this message
out
especially to the new developments
that's my opinion
yes excuse me if i
just check with catherine green regard
that i haven't told you incorrectly
about the
maximum affair if you travel outside of
the district it's i've what just like to
check with one of our offices
if that's all right is that correct
catherine i believe so yes thank you
just want to be 100 sure i'm still only
15 months or so into licensing so i
wouldn't want to tell you wrong
thank you thank you very much and we we
appreciate that the dual role here today
or even triple um
with is kimberly in the back isn't it
kimberly kerry i beg your pardon kerry
thank you
catherine um councillor brandon thank
you chair
um yes i must admit i didn't know
that the fares displayed were the
maximum fares i thought that
was the fair um
and i would guess that that's probably
the majority of
of the public who use
taxis and cabs i wonder
whether it would be within regulations
or whether we can
make a suggestion that
taxis have to have a sticker
explaining that
it is it's on it's on the tariff table
it does say maximum hackney carriage
fares allowed
um yeah we could raise awareness of it i
think
yes yeah
sorry um yeah i agree with catherine
as a person who just gets in a taxi and
to see the meter spinning round
i don't think many people in the general
public were aware about a maximum and
they just see it going round and think
that's what they got to pay
end of but i do think generally people
who are doing longer distances and taxi
probably whether it's the stance that to
go on a holiday or
whatever they do do tend to try and get
a price and don't have a meeting running
before they start
those sorts of journeys would normally
book with a private hire operator and
agreed
correct yes uh
thank you very much there is just one
item that i would like to raise with you
which is
um at the bottom of appendix a where it
says no extra charge should be made for
luggage shopping assistance dogs
wheelchairs or mobility scooters i would
personally
like to see their put in their
disability apparatus we can certainly do
that's no problem
thank you yes as an amendment
um i'm going to ask karen or rob
if we we've already been it's already
been suggested
that 3.2 is likely altered
do we need to take a vote or make a
comment on the very last
comment that i have made on appendix a
yeah we need a proposer who would then
um
if they wish add that to their proposal
okay fine thank you thank you um
i think we have finished all the
questions from councillors so i would
like to
to move that um we
take this um proposal and i'm just
trying to get to the
3.2 sorry the computer is always slow uh
to 3.2
with the wording and also the alteration
are
the very last item
um so the recommendations are
councillors
um 3.1 that the committee considered the
two options set out in 2.1
and also 3.2 that the committee
proposes or the committee
forwards what word would you like there
because we can't resolve
would you like me to clarify yes please
karen thank you
i've got um that the committee agrees to
recommend a cabinet that the table
affairs be amended
as per appendix a and therefore
instructs
officers to proceed with the public
consultation notice
advertising the variations in accordance
with section 65 of the local government
miscellaneous provisions act 1976
the very table affair shall become
effective from the 1st of november
2021 thank you and we need a composer
and a second
of course yes councillor beer just wants
to comment at the moment
yes at what point
will that come back to us as a committee
before it gets to cabinet because
if cabinet are going to make accept the
recommendation
sorry um cancel we did discuss that and
that's going to come back to us on the
13th of august
did that know the 13th of august was the
date suggested thank you
yes thank you thank you very much um
councillors are you do you actually
understand 3.2 um
are you in agreement to the wording
everyone yes
yes um i have proposed it if i could
have
a secondary
secondary seconded from councillor ayers
so the wording of 3.2 will be as karen
read out to us plus there will be the
amendment
at the very end which alters it to
disability apparatus
and your secondary is happy with that
yes thank you
are we going to a vote now please yep
set up the vote and that's ready now in
the modern.gov app
thank you
um it doesn't actually say does it about
the alteration on the very end
are we just taking that as read
karen this is the recommendation
the amend amendment to appendix a at the
very end yes where it says disability
apparatus
do we need to put that in writing or are
we taking that as read
perhaps we need our legal
expert here please well i i think that
the
meeting has been ministered and recorded
accordingly so i think that will be
sufficient to include that amendment
thank you very much for that ruling
thank you um and we all need
to vote now it may well be that i'm the
only one who hasn't voted yet because it
won't let me vote
that's exciting
i have now voted apologies it was being
slow
thank you chair the vote is in and that
is carried
seven votes for thank you very much just
go back to the agenda where we can get
there
yes it's just taking the time to get
there
thank you very thank you very much
councillors that concludes the business
on the agenda just to confirm the date
and time of the next meeting
which is friday the 13th of august 2021
at 9
30 and i thank you all for attending
and thank you also to all the officers
who have given a lot of time for this
subject
thank you very much
you